[Music]
let's go out to shane in columbus
ohio hey shane what's going on man
oh not too much how are you guys doing
we're good brother how can we help
yeah so i guess the the question that i
have
is in regards to student loans and kind
of
how i should think about structuring my
life and that kind of thing
you went from student loans to how do i
structure my life
they got real tactical to existential
we'll do what we can go
go for it right so
um i'm 31 i make
not quite 58 dollars a year at the
moment and i have a hundred and sixty
five thousand dollars in student loan
debt
whoa what'd you get degrees in brother
architecture
are you in the field i i am
i'm in the field um working toward my
license and that kind of thing
okay um how far away are you oh it's
two exams two exams what does your
income do when you
are fully licensed is it double is it
triple i guess it's kind of endless if
you open your own firm
that's that's a question that i've been
trying to figure out
um the answers vary wildly either
making what i make now or making
somewhere close to
90 or 100. okay
um are you clear you don't have to tell
us but are you
clear on what what must be true for you
to make 100
um i think so
i at least in the job that i have right
now
if i were to make that much or near that
much
i would end up being in a project
manager type role
um i'm not sure how long out that would
be maybe
five or six years if i had to guess yeah
here's the problem
uh we'll get to the money stuff in a
second but this is really important you
don't need to be thinking and you don't
need to be guessing
you need to be knowing and you need to
be doing do you understand what i'm
saying
i think so you have a hundred and
sixty-five
thousand dollars in student loan debt
yeah
so yeah and you have and you have to you
have a terrific education
and you're about your two tests away
from getting licenses that's going to
open up a lot
my point is you need to do more research
and know what the path looks like to be
a project manager in this current
company or know what it takes to make
100 somewhere else
you need to know that not guess not
think that's what i'm making sure you
understand
what are the multiple pathways for me to
make more money for me to get promoted
do you understand what i'm saying now
you need to know that
you can't just think about it you can't
guess we know how do we find that out
shane
we start talking to people that are
higher up the ladder than you are
they know because they've done it do you
understand
yeah all right what is the fear you have
in finding out
the exact precise path or location or
destination
is there a part of you that looks at
that 165 and thinks
oh i may not have a path and it's better
just to not know why why
haven't you gone and just gotten the
brass tacks on the numbers in the path
here
so part of it has been
i spent i spent a few years in a life
situation that was total garbage
okay um so there was that and then
i'm finally getting through that
so now it's a matter of i'm finally in a
place where i don't feel unstable all
the time
excellent so now i'm looking at the
future but i'm not sure if i'm
ready to take on the amount of
responsibility that would
get me the job that pays the 900
plus um that's what i'm saying it would
be
in a couple of years i don't feel that i
would be
in a position in my personal life
to take on that role at this time you're
being awfully cryptic
be a little more descriptive because
here's the thing you've boxed yourself
into a corner
with a hundred and sixty-five thousand
dollars in debt
right and so you got into a ring with a
big fighter already and now you're
trying to decide whether you want to
actually fight him or not
so in some ways that ship has sailed but
i do understand having seasons in my
life when i think i can't handle
or i can't stomach the amount of
responsibility it would take for xy i
get that
but you're being kind of cryptic when
you say i don't know if i'm ready it's
gonna be a couple of years
are you suffering from mental illness
are you dealing with a divorce like what
are you working through
um yeah there's mental illness
um and
just exp like having the experience
level like i'm not
confident that i would be able to take
it on like i'm
the job that i'm at now is bringing me
along and i am taking on more
um but it's the kind of situation where
the to go from where i'm at now
to the project manager position my
responsibility triples or quadrupoles
okay and at the particular firm you're
at
right at the furlong map but also just
from you know colleagues that i have and
other
jobs that i've been at that seems to be
the standard is they're working all the
time
they have a lot of responsibility
they're managing
a ton of people and i just don't
like i said my responsibility would
quadruple overnight
if i were to do that today all right all
right so that's fair yep
that's fair and and and so here's the
good news well let's talk
you know we'll walk you through how to
get out of debt and walk you through the
baby steps if you're not familiar with
it but but understand this
that whether or not you're ready and
let's just assume that i get where
you're going here you're not ready for
that and it's going to take a little bit
of time to be able to earn that
responsibility i totally understand what
you're saying makes total sense
so in the meantime we got to go do
something else we got to work a little
bit more get a second job because
we need to get out of this debt you're
31 years of age
um and and you need to get out of this
debt as quickly as possible so the best
way to do that
is to increase your income because
obviously we're going to teach you how
to
cut cut cut your expenses rice and beans
and the whole nine yards okay
but raising that income is also
something that's going to allow this to
go faster
that's exactly right and here's the
thing i want you to remember two things
as
ken walks you through this if your boss
if your supervisor comes to you and says
we think you're ready for more
very few bosses are that altruistic
are just going to give you something the
reason they would give that to you is
because they think you're qualified or
they think
to be crass about it they think you're
going to make them more money
and so when somebody looks at me here's
a good example
um when dave and i were discussing me
joining this team
um one time we were talking about
negotiating salary negotiations all that
and i said dave you are asking me to
take a job
that i've never done i've never been on
the radio
and he looked at me and said i think you
can do it and i remember leaving
thinking
that sounds nuts number one but number
two he wouldn't
shoot a hole in his own ship just
because and so
that confidence got me into
radio school and practicing all those
things that we had to do to end up being
on the show does that make sense
yeah so when you are in your dark
seasons whatever your challenges are
when you're in those moments i want you
to remember your community defines your
calling they're going to be looking at
you saying hey
we think you're ready for this and that
often
is somebody lifting your arms up in the
desert man they are seeing things and
you you can't see and it's
it's good like indiana jones you go
trust them you take that next step in
that next step
so go ahead and by the way it's like
parenting you're not ready for parenting
either it just happens
you just have to do it yeah you have to
do okay shane so assuming the only debt
you have
is the 165 000 student loans is that
correct
um or do you have other debt yes okay
yeah all right so here's the deal baby
step one you're gonna put a thousand
dollars
in a savings account that is your
emergency fund one thousand dollars okay
and then baby step two is we take on the
debt and so let's say you've got three
different loans or two different loans
we're going to start on the smallest
debt first and you're going to attack it
with everything you got
every extra nickel we want to get your
budget as tight as possible cut
cut cut sell everything you can sell get
a second job
third job whatever and you're gonna
attack that
smallest student loan and once you pay
that off everything you've been paying
into that
you roll it over into the next largest
one and eventually
you're gonna pay all of those off and
then you're gonna move into baby step
three which is to put three to six
months of your expenses
in an emergency fund that gets you to
baby step four where you begin to put 15
percent of your income away
for retirement hey ken i'll talk about
that last caller real quick
um we had a young man who was 165
000 in student loan debt he is two exams
away from being a licensed
architect um making about 60 grand
then life hit him in the mouth right
he's struggling with some mental health
challenges he had some relationship
issues and to make the money he's going
to need to make to pay this student loan
office in a reasonable time frame
he now understands whoa that's going to
be a lot more responsibility it's going
to be four times the workload that's 24
7 365 that kind of stuff
so it got me thinking about um
man i always wanted to be a
executive at a university that was a job
i was like i'd planned that
and so i built a world around that and
when i got the right credentials i
started working in these ways
until i started spending time around
executives and i remember
the moment when i thought i don't want
that life
right i don't want that job i want that
life and it was an existential crisis
for me because i'd spent
years sure money time all that investing
in this track and when i got close
enough to it i thought oh man
and then as i've worked with college
students law students especially they
get
one semester away from you know law
school and they say
i don't want to practice law right or i
don't like this grind but i owe 150
grand what do i do
ken what do we tell people and i'm this
isn't a setup for the audience
i'm i'm i'm wondering like what do you
tell somebody when they realize
oh man first thing i tell them is don't
feel guilty
be grateful now let me explain that
don't
feel some sense of shame or guilt like
oh i didn't get it i missed it
so i spent all this time and money
thinking i was going one direction
only to get there and realize i don't
want to do this there's so much guilt
and shame that people feel yeah
so let's first address that i would go
hey hey hey listen
it's okay yeah i'm i'm actually thrilled
you figured it out
now right as opposed to never figuring
it out or
figuring it out and denying it yes and
biting your lip and spinning a life of
tremendous misery which affects your
personal life affects
everything everything and by the way i
do what i do by the way it's like i
don't want people to just
be miserable in a career so the first
thing is don't feel guilt or shame
be grateful that you figured it out and
then go okay so that's the first thing
so
so there's that you were going to say
something i was going to say and
i reject the notion when people get
through with a degree and they go on to
do something else
that they say i quote unquote wasted all
of
not true you had to that's the very
thing i'm talking about okay so yeah you
had
this many professors think of that as
you have this many bosses this much
community you learned a lot it's in the
rearview mirror there you go i mean i
could sit there all day long and tell
you all the great things that you've
benefited from but
but that's the wrong narrative that's
why i'm saying no guilt no shame
be grateful that you figured it out now
in his situation let's take shane our
last caller
and this was not his situation but
you're setting up a point that by the
way is very relevant
i get this call all the time on the ken
coleman show so i say look if you don't
want to go into architecture we'll just
use this example
great however if you got 165 000
in loans it might be a good idea to take
two or three years
and move forward move up the ladder in
architecture because you're
trained for that and it might be your
best opportunity
to make the money the big shovel that
dave ramsey talks about
to pay off the debt and we're only
talking about two to three years
and while you're doing that you might be
able to cash flow the qualifying process
for something else
and it and by the way let's not assume
that i got to go get another four-year
degree
exactly so let's just use a real-life
example let's say that that somebody
goes and does the architectural they got
165 000 in debt
and they go i don't want to be an
architect i'm miserable there's no way i
can do that well they can either
stay in architecture and pay off the
debt or they can go
well what do i really want to do and
let's just assume they figure out that
they want to go into technology
and instead of building and designing
buildings they want to design software
very similar parts of the brain by the
way right let's just assume that's what
they say they go okay
i want to be a programmer and design
software or whatever
okay great so the first inclinations
they go well i'm gonna have to go get a
computer science degree which is running
about 160 180 thousand dollars you can't
do that i'm already 165 000
what do i do well the ken coleman show
partners with bethel tech which is just
one
of a ton of options bethel tech
will train you me anybody
in nine months to go from zero
technology experience
to where you're qualified to start
making seventy five thousand dollars a
year with a path quickly to six figures
and more
whether it be a developer or technology
engineer whatever
they can do it nine month program less
than 15 grand that's just one
example of wait a second i could get out
of debt and cash flow a bridge a
transition
to a new future so that's what i always
do is say hey
let's figure out where we want to go and
then we decide
which path we take to get out of debt
and the temptation is to sit in the ash
of what was and just be like well this
is it
so i got to stick with architecture i
know you don't i'm sentencing myself to
a lifetime of misery for one bad
decision
that's exactly right so first thing no
guilt no shame
let's be grateful that we figured it out
now let's get intentional
and stage one of my seven stages the
work you were born to do is get clear
let's get clear on what it is we want to
do
second stage is get qualified third
stage is get connected
and eventually we get started in stage
four so we may have to and i want to be
very realistic right now i don't want
this to sound
motivational oh it's just three stages
no that's hard work
and sometimes years right well it took
me seven years to get to ramsey
solutions and then three more
before i stepped into my dream job so
i'm at 10 years decade
a decade to get to my dream job now in
this case it may take you two to three
years to get out of debt
and i would i would place uh i would
press pause rather
on the journey if that's what it took
because here's the deal it's going to be
worth it in the end
i may delay the transition
to what i really want to do two to three
years but what's the alternative
never doing it never and being stuck in
debt for 25 30 years of your life that's
right or
dying with debt so my wife has uh some
friends
and they tell a great story they they
were 35 and they were on a date and
one of them said to the other you know
what i kind of kicked myself
i'm 35 i'd always wanted to go to law
school i mean uh med school yeah
to which the spouse replied i never told
you but i want to go to med school too
and they were telling somebody and they
said man we're not going to do that
we're not going to be out of school
until we're 42 and
that person wisely said this you're
gonna be 42 either way
the only question you should be asking
is do you want to be 42 and a doctor or
42 and not a doctor
it's absolutely beautiful whoa we're
headed that way anyway
right absent a meteorite or a car wreck
so
man what if we just started walking that
away i was 33 when
i realized that it was not politics it
was going to be broadcasting but i
didn't have a college degree
and i didn't hardly know anybody and i
didn't have any experience and i had
three little kids under the age of three
that's my story yeah 33
dude finishing my dissertation thinking
i don't think this is what i want to do
yeah and we're all in
you know what that means uh oh i got to
go take another class
another class and here we go the whole
thing and my wife said
mean i think i want to stick around for
another right where i have to
walk this whole thing it's hard sure
it's hard
but listen but you're going to be 42
either way yeah here's the deal
once you figure out that thing and by
the way
there's multiple jobs and career paths
that are your that could be your thing
that's what i teach no ken there's only
one thing what is the thing
no not just one thing just like there's
one dream person like titanic
no it's not true here's here's here and
by the way here's how you know
as long as you're using your talent to
do work you love
to produce results that matter deeply to
you ding ding ding that's a dream job
so there's a lot of things a lot of
things you could do
so relax a little bit yeah do the hard
work
own it but for heaven's sakes john i'm
so glad you asked the question because
there are so many men and women who feel
like they blew it
and they're stuck but they're choosing
you know stuck
is your choice everybody thinks that
well this happened to me i'm stuck
uh i'm not questioning what happened to
you
uh but you're choosing to be stuck
you really are because i've gotten my
car stuck before on the beach
i've got my car stuck in the snow back
in fact this last snow we got in
nashville
and i could have just sat there and went
well stacy i'm stuck
gonna have to sit here until the snow
melts or until somebody comes along this
deserted area of the beach and digs me
out
no i got my butt out of the freaking car
and i got down
on my hands and knees and dug out gloves
because i'm an idiot
and dug myself out because it's the
rockies because being stuck
is your choice and getting unstuck is
also your choice
ugly action well thanks for talking
through that with me
man my heart's with shane